jean philippe dugoin clément vice
président de la région ile de france en
charge de l'écologie du développement
durable et de l'aménagement urbain
bonsoir merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
sur rt france on a vu la défaite de
rachida dati ce soir est ce que paris a
choisi l'écologie selon vous bonsoir
non je crois que paris a fait un choix
par défaut la réalité c'est que anne
hidalgo a été élu avec moins de 50% des
voix en bénéficiant et bien de la
division en bénéficiant du fait que
madame but sain et choisit de maintenir
une candidature qui ne pouvaient plus
permettre de gagner mais uniquement de
maintenir anne hidalgo en fonction avec
tout ce que nous subissons en ile de
france depuis des années avec une ville
de paris qui fonctionnent en autarcie
complet après on constate globalement
par rapport aux municipales de 2014 où
le curseur est année extrêmement loin
avec une vague de centre droit et de
droite extrêmement élevé que le curseur
reviens petit peu en arrière ce qui
bénéficie aussi à madame hidalgo
finalement quel signe cette poussée des
écologistes ce soir est ce que ça va
amener les parties un peu plus
traditionnels notamment à droite à se
réinventer sur cette question-là de
l'écologie moi je souhaite lui d y est
un parti celui dont je fais partie qui
porte ces valeurs au sein de la région
ile-de-france avec valérie pécresse
nous avons mis en place un programme de
transition environnementale extrêmement
puissant c'est plus de 10 milliards
d'euros que nous investissons nous avons
dès cette année investi 2 milliards
d'euros plus d'un euro sur deux dépensés
en ile de france et un euro consacré la
transition environnementale mais moi je
pense que aujourd'hui l'écologie doit
devenir une priorité pour l'ensemble des
partis politiques pour l'ensemble des
formations politiques et ne pas être
cantonné à un parti qui est aujourd'hui
un parti extrêmement à gauche qui a une
vision extrêmement dogmatique de
l'environnement et/ou d'ailleurs on va
voir la façon dont ils sont amenés à
gérer les communes qu'ils prennent mais
va y avoir la question de la preuve par
l'exemple et moi j'attends aujourd'hui
que ces questions environnementales
elles soient prises à bras le corps par
les partis traditionnels
je fais partie de ceux dans les
délégations qui sont les miennes qui
push sur ces sujets là
mais nous avons des enjeux majeurs la
problématique de la peur d'un monde les
problématiques de marche pour le climat
que nous avions connus avant la crise du
comité mais ne se sont pas envolés les
problématiques de pollution de l'air qui
chaque année en france tue plus que le
covin elles ne se sont pas envolés les
problématiques de transition énergétique
qui font que notre pays est complètement
dépendant énergétiquement ces sujets là
ne se sont pas envolées donc je crois
qu'on a un champ entier à devoir
travailler à devoir investiguer et que
ça va être le sujet des mois et des
années qui viennent après on constate
quand même sur cette élection alors
effectivement stéphane rosa se disait
beaucoup de facteurs locaux avec des
effets parfois amortisseurs ou des
effets qui peuvent aggraver ou renforcer
une dynamique mais on constate surtout
que la gauche s'est resserré sur ses
valeurs s'est resserré sur des valeurs
de gauche traditionnelle de gauche un
peu moins social démocrate et que la
faiblesse du parti socialiste fait que
celle europe ecologie les verts qui tire
la martingale et qui est faiseur de deux
victoires selon-vous europe ecologie les
verts pour le parti socialiste en
l'occurrence je vous pose une deuxième
question dans la foulée le parti
présidentiel à emmanuel macron en
l'occurrence veut se repositionner aussi
sur le monde d'après cette question de
l'écologie vous le croyez vaut mieux
qu'ils se positionnent sur le monde est
d'après que le monde d'aujourd'hui ce
que le monde d'aujourd'hui s'il défaite
que milan n'a jamais eu pour un parti
présidentiel sur des municipales fin on
est sur un parti présidentiel qui perd
les quelques grandes villes qu'ils
avaient et qu'il ne craint plus le
parent ce qu'on constate aujourd'hui
c'est que le parti du président de la
république quel que soit sont ces
possibilités son destin national en 2022
n'a absolument pas mailler le territoire
français et qu'on est sur une france qui
est complètement coupée en deux entre un
état d'un côté et des réalités
territoriales on a le cas aux
municipales mais on va le voir également
l'année prochaine c'est des élections de
francs par pousser au départemental et
aux régionales et le président de la
république
effectivement aujourd'hui intérêt à
tirer très vite un trait là dessus parce
que c'est objectivement un vote sanction
absolument
terrible ce soir alors en tout cas jean
philippe dugoin clément ce soir on l'a
constaté la marque la république en
marche
et bien cela n'a pas fonctionné comment
est ce que vous le comprenez comment
est-ce que vous l'expliquer tout
simplement parce qu une élection
municipale ce n'est pas une élection
nationale et qu' on n'est pas élu maire
sur une étiquette politique ou en tout
cas pas seulement
et les candidats rennes ou de la
majorité qui ont été élus ils n'ont été
est-ce qu'ils avaient un ancrage local
c'est le cas d'edouard philippe c'est le
cas d'un certain nombre de ministres ou
secrétaires d'état on peut parler de
darmana ou d'autres mais de francs crise
terme et ceux qui ont été réélus ils
l'ont été du fait d'un ancrage local
pas à cause d'une marque et à la limite
la marque ici elle a plutôt joué comme
une sanction
elle a plutôt été pénalisantes parce
qu'il ya un certain nombre
d'incompréhensions on mesure bien le le
point de de malaise qu'il peut y avoir
auprès d'un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens
donc cette marque outre le fait qu'elle
ne poussait pas elle était plutôt sur
une logique de gêner ou de ralentir on
le voit bien depuis les européennes
entre le nombre de dés lui de centre
gauche de centre-droit qui courait après
des demandes d'investiture et puis qui
après les avoir eus sont allés plutôt en
arrière de les cacher pour se re
localiser on mesure bien ce décalage là
et puis il ya je crois un autre sujet
qui est un sujet de fond on voit bien la
poussée de leur tour un petit peu de de
la gauche mais la poussée des questions
environnementales
moi je crois que le sujet majeur qui va
intéresser notre pays et qui va
intéresser les pays développés dans les
cinq six dix ans qui viennent
c'est le sujet de l'environnement c'est
le sujet de
comment est ce qu'on a sur une
soutenabilité une pérennité au monde
dans lequel on vient dans lequel on vit
et la réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui le
gouvernement
mais comme les gouvernements des grands
pays développés ne donne pas le
sentiment à leurs citoyens qu'ils
apportent des réponses à l'enjeu
environnemental à la hauteur de ce qui
est attendu
et je pense que le grand sujet
aujourd'hui ça va être de faire des
questions environnementales
la question prioritaire de montrer que
la ou les collectivités jc existent et
agissent
extrêmement puissamment les états sont
également capables de le faire
mais ne nous trompons pas de sujet c'est
pas le faire avec un environnement
punitif c'est pas le faire avec un
environnement qui soit une machine a
accentué la récession
c'est le fer avec une vision positive de
l'environnement avec une vision concrète
de l'environnement avec un environnement
qui peut réinvestir dans nos territoires
qui peut recréer de l'emploi et je crois
profondément profondément que l'enjeu du
président de la république et son
premier ministre quel qu'il soit dans
les mois qui viennent ça sera s'ils
veulent avoir une pérennité au delà de
2022 d'être capable de donner des gages
mais dégage réel c'est pas de qu'on
aille au delà de la simple communication
vous allez les gens sont pas des idiots
ils veulent des actes ils veulent des
choses qui soient tangibles et ça sera
l'enjeu des années qui viennent